UNSEEN SEGMENT WHERE WE EXPOSE
THE FORCES THAT SHAPED THE
MIDTERMS.
RAY, YOU HAVE SOME LESSONS FOR
THOSE SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE IN
THE FUTURE.
>> YOU KNOW, THESE MIDTERMS WERE
INSTRUCTIVE, LAURA.
THERE WAS MUCH TO LEARN FROM THE
CANDIDATES WHO DIDN'T MAKE IT.
FIRST RULE, DON'T TRY SINGING AT
A CAMPAIGN EVENT IF YOU CAN'T
SING.
THIS IS DON BOLDUC --
♪ COUNTRY ROADS
TAKE ME HOME
TO THE PLACE
I BELONG
♪♪
♪ WEST VIRGINIA
MOUNTAIN MAMA
TAKE ME HOME
COUNTRY ROADS
♪♪
>> OH, BOY.
MAY I RECOMMEND THE MASKED
SINGER FOR HIM.
UNLESS YOU'RE AUDITIONING FOR
DANCING WITH THE WANNABE STARS
WHICH COULD BE CAREER OPTIONS
FOR THE NEXT TWO CANDIDATES,
DON'T DANCE IN PUBLIC LIKE
STACEY OR BETO.
♪♪
THICK IN HIPS COME GET IN MY CAR
THE LONG HAIRED STAR, THE THICK
IN THE HIPS, COME GET IN MY CAR.
♪♪
>> I DIDN'T KNOW --
>> QUALIFYING FOR OFFICE, LAURA.
HOW DOES THAT PROVE YOUR
LEADEVERSHIP ABILITY? I ASK
?
YOU?>> LAURA: REMEMBER, OBAMA
COULD SING.
WHEN HE SANG AL GREEN, HE HAS A
GOOD VOICE.
BUT --
>> HE WON THE OFFICE BY THAT
POINT, THOUGH.
>> LAURA: THAT'S TRUE.
>> HE WASN'T CAMPAIGNING.
>> THIS IS STILL WHAT THEY'RE
DECIDING.
>> THE MOST VEXING MOMENT OF THE
NIGHT CAME OUT OF PENNSYLVANIA
THAT BROUGHT YOU JOHN FETTERMAN.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS WRONG WHEN
A MAN WHO'S BEEN DEAD FOR A
MONTH IS ELECTED STATE
REPRESENTATIVE.
TONY DeLUCA DIED LAST MONTH.
HE WAS RE-ELECTED LAST NIGHT.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
AFTER FETTERMAN, LAURA,
EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE.
>> LAURA: OKAY, THAT IS
TERRIFYING.
RAY, WHY DO YOU THINK THE RED
WAVE FAILED TO MATERIALIZE?
>> LAURA, WHAT DID I SAY? I GOT
NASTY EMAILS AND TWEETS IN THE
LAST FEW MONTHS.
I SAID OVER AND OVER, LET'S GO
BRANDON IS NOT A GOVERNING
AGENDA.
YOU NEED A CLEAR ACTIONABLE
SERIES OF POLICIES THAT YOU CAN
DEFEND AND ADVANCE.
GIVE THE VOTERSOMING TO ASPIRE
TO.
THE GOP DIDN'T DO THAT.
THEY HAVE THAT COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA, BUT, LAURA, I WILL READ
TWO QUICK GOALS -- ECONOMY
THAT'S STRONG, A FUTURE BUILT ON
FREEDOM.
THOSE ARE NOT POLICY ACTION
ITEMS.
THOSE ARE JUST HOPES.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO -- THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH MEAT THERE ON THE
BONE.
LAURA, WHEN YOU PEAL BACK THE
POLLING DATA, IT WAS YOUNG
VOTERS THAT GAVE THE DEMOCRATS
THE ADVANTAGE.
OF ALL OF THE AGE GROUPS, IT WAS
GENZ WHO DELIVERED FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
THEY MOSTLY LIVE WITH THEIR
PARENTS. THEY VOTED 6 % OF THEM
FOR DEMOCRATS, THAT'S PLUS 28
POINTS FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND MAY HAVE BLUNTED THE RED
WAVE THAT CAME FROM OTHER
GROUPS.
>> LAURA: I THINK A LOT OF THE
YOUNGER PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, THE
LOCKDOWN WASN'T MAYBE SO BAD,
RIGHT? FOR THEM? THEY GOT TO --
>> HMM.
>> LAURA: GOT TO ORDER UBER EATS
AND CATCH UP ON THE NETFLIX AND
GET THEIR CHECKS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WERE ALSO VERY
DELIBERATE IN THEIR PITCH TO
YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEY OFFERED THEM DRUGS,
RECREATIONAL DRUGS, ABORTION,
PAID OFF STUDENT LOANS.
SO, THEY WERE, AGAIN, ACTIONABLE
POLICIES THAT THEY WERE
PROMISING TO ADVANCE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND THE GOP DID NOT GET IN THE
MUD AND WRESTLE OVER ANY OF
THESE ISSUES TRYING TO WIN THE
YOUNG PEOPLE OVER.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE.
DESPITE THE SETBACK OF LOSING AT
LEAST ONE HOUSE OF CONGRESS,
BIDEN WAS BACK AT BEING THE OLD
BIDEN APT HIS PRESS CONFERENCE
TONIGHT, LAURA.
>> I'VE BEEN GIVEN A LIST OF TEN
PEOPLE I'M SUPPOSED TO CALL ON.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO ASK ONE
QUESTION, WHETHER OR NOT, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF, IN FACT, I
THINK THE CONTEXT IS THAT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE PULLING
BACK FROM FALLUJAH.
AND THE -- I MEAN THE -- THE
CITY OF KURSON BEING A -- A --
BY -- BIDEN'S BEING EXTREMIST.
>> OH, LAURA.
CLARITY SHOULD BE THE MANDATE, I
THINK, COMING OUT OF THESE
MIDTERMS.
>> LAURA: THIS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING, THE MSNBC GAL WAS LIKE,
WOW HERSCHEL WALKER CANNOT
STRING TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER.
HAS SHE LISTENED TO BIDEN,
FETTERMAN? COME ON.
HE'S SOCRATES COMPARED TO THE
OTHER TWO.
COME ON.
OF.
>> REMARKABLE.
>> LAURA: WHERE ARE YOU GOING
NEXT, THE BOOK TOUR THAT NEVER
ENDS.
>> BIRMINGHAM, ALABAMA O